I just wanted to hop on here
and show you how I do my planning for the day.
Um, so this is like my master.
This is the main little master book that I have
that I just consistently go day by day and write down,
um, my to do list per se.
Now, I do a method called brain dumping.
I did not come up with this. Um,
someone else did.
But essentially,
you go through
and you just think, like,
anything that just comes to mind,
you just jot it down
and you make a giant list
and then you section them.
So I have on here top three.
So you section them
by the top three things I need to get done on that day.
The Easy 3. So, like,
the tasks that are easier.
So I had, like, laundry,
picking up our bedroom,
cleaning off our desk
that we have.
That is our catch all.
And then the next three.
So the next three things.
Next three things you want to do after that
I find very helpful for me. Um, I.
I swear I have ADHD or something.
Just the way my brain works,
it's hard for me to stay on task.
Um, and with this,
it's easier because I can,
like I said,
brain dump everything out of my brain
onto a piece of paper where I can visually see it.
So I just thought I would share this little method.
It is very Helpful for me.
And it may be helpful for you